N
MAVERICK HELPED BOOST SUPPORT
FOR THE NAVY.
>> Todd: I WOULD AGREE WITH
THAT.
TURNING TO THE BORDER CRISIS.
MORE MIGRANT BUSES ARRIVING IN
NEW YORK CITY AND ALL AS TEXAS
GOVERNOR GREG ABBOTT CALLING OUT
NEW YORK CITY MAYOR ERIC ADAMS
FOR THE NYPD FOR PULLING OVER
AND TICKETING SOME BUSES FROM
THE LONE STAR STATE.
>> Carly: THIS IS ANOTHER
PATHETIC PLOY FROM ABBOTT
SENDING THEM TO SANCTUARY CITIES
AND EACH BUS USED FOR THE STATE
OF TEXAS UNDERGOES A THOROUGH
TEXAS DIDN'T OF PUBLIC SAFETY,
COMMERCIAL VEHICLE INSPECTION
BEFORE DEPARTING FOR SANCTUARY
CITIES.
JOINING US LIVE IS FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR LARA TRUMP.
LARA, THE NEW YORK POST IS
REPORTING THAT MEMBERS OF THE
NYPD SPENT HOURS METICULOUSLY
SEARCHING EACH BUS FOR ANY
POSSIBLE INFRACTION, BOOKING
LOGS, TREAD TIRES, FUEL LEVELS
AND WINDSHIELD WIPER PLACEMENTS
AND THESE ARE THE BUSS THAT ARE
PULLING INTO PORT AUTHORITY AND
DROPPING THE MIGRANTS OFF.
THE GOAL IS TO GET THE BUSES OFF
THE ROAD SO THE MIGRANTS STOP
COMING.
IS THAT GOING TO WORK?
>> WELL, IT'S A GOOD THING
THERE'S NOT A CRIME CRISIS GOING
ON IN NEW YORK CITY.
OH, WAIT, THERE IS.
THIS IS WHERE THE NYPD IS
FOCUSING THEIR TIME.
IT TURNS OUT WHENEVER YOU
VIOLATE THE LAWS ON THE SOUTHERN
BORDER AND ALLOW THAT TO HAPPEN,
IT'S A PROBLEM ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
ASK THE PEOPLE DOWN IN TEXAS HOW
IT'S BEEN FOR THEM.
IT IS AMAZING TO SEE THESE
SANCTUARY CITIES THAT WHENEVER
THEY'RE FACED WITH AN INFLUX OF
PEOPLE COMING IN, THEY CAN'T
DEAL WITH IT.
THAT IS THE REASON WHY WE HAVE
THE LAWS WE HAVE IN PLACE AT OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER.
BUT, NO, DO I THINK THIS WILL
DETER ANYTHING, CARLY?
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
IT'S OUTRAGEOUS TO SEE ERIC
ADAMS, MAYOR OF NEW YORK CITY,
AND EX-COP EMPLOY TACTICS LIKE
THIS AND TARGETING ENFORCEMENT
OF LAWS, WHICH YOU CAN'T DO IF
HE HAS A GRIEVANCE WITH WHAT'S
GOING ON AND INFLUX OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS COMING TO HIS AREA
AND OUR COUNTRY, HE CAN TARGET
1600 PENNSYLVANIA AVENUE BECAUSE
IT IS THE POLICIES OF JOE BIDEN
AND KAMALA HARRIS, THE BORDER
CZAR, THAT HAVE LED US DOWN THIS
PATH.
IT IS UNSUSTAINABLE.
AMAZING TO SEE THESE ISN'T WARE
CITIES TAKE HOLD. HOLD.
>> Todd: YOU MENTIONED KAMALA
AND WE SAW THE LATEST BUS
ARRIVAL.
HERE'S THE VICE PRESIDENT LAST
NIGHT ONSET MEYERS.
ON SETH MEYERS.
>> I THINK IT'S AN ABSOLUTE
DERELICTION OF DUTY AND IF YOU
SEE A PROBLEM AND WE AGREE WE
NEED TO ADDRESS IF, IF YOU'RE A
LEADER, PARTICIPATE IN A
SOLUTION.
WHEN WE FIRST CAME IN OFFICE,
THE FIRST BILL WE PROPOSED WAS
FOR A PATHWAY FOR CITIZENSHIP.
IT WAS TO FIX A BROKEN
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM, THAT WAS
BROKEN UNDER THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION.
PARTICIPATE IN THE SOLUTION
BECAUSE WE ARE OFFERING
SOLUTIONS.
INSTEAD THIS GAMESMANSHIP WITH
REAL HUMAN BEINGS WHO TRUST US.
>> Todd: I NEED A 10 SECOND
AINSLEY MY FRIEND.
IF YOU ARE A LEADER, AREN'T YOU
THE BORDER CZAR, KAMALA?
>> YES, A DERELICTION OF DUTIES
SAYS THE BORDER CZAR WHO WAS IN
THE BORDER ONCE AND WAS IN TEXAS
LAST WEEK AND DID NOT BOTHER TO
GO DOWN THERE, GIVE US ALL A
BREAK.
WE KNOW WHO'S CAUSING THIS AND
THEY KNOW IT'S A GREEN LIT
SITUATION AND EVERY PERSON
COMING OVER